Congratulations, you've made it to the end of this unit. And what we've been
doing, is what's called object oriented design. And, I've avoided using that
term so far both because I think it's hard to say, and it's not the most
pleasant of terms. The important point is that, we've been developing techniques
to manage complexity by dividing complex problems into objects. And the objects
can be combined to solve the problem that we care about. This is different from
procedural programming. That we focused on for the first seven units of the
class. Where we're solving a complex problem by dividing it into procedures that
can be combine to solve the problem. The difference is objects providing
encapsulation. We can combine procedures and data, and complex data all into one
object and us that object as one thing. The way we do this in Python is use
class to make new types and inheritance to reuse classes to create lots of new
classes. So thanks for sticking through the end of the unit. And at this point
you really are a powerful programmer. You've got the tools to manage complex
programs. And you should be able to start really creating interesting programs
on your own. One thing we haven't talked about yet, is how to deal with the rest
of the world in your programs. That's what we'll get to in the next unit. Hope
to see you there.